[Música]
el 19 de septiembre es una jornada que
marca la historia de méxico
el mismo día con 32 años de diferencia
la nación azteca fue golpeada por dos
grandes terremotos en 1985 y en 2017
dolor miedo angustia y tragedia son
palabras que describen lo ocurrido en
ambas fechas cuando miles de mexicanos
vieron cómo cambiaba su vida de un
minuto para otro en 1985 méxico aprendió
que necesitaba mejores estrategias en
caso de una nueva tragedia y el temido
día llegó 32 años después la mañana del
19 de septiembre del 2017 los mexicanos
esperaban conmemorar a los fallecidos en
1985 nadie imaginaba que ese mismo día
se repitiera la catástrofe gracias a los
avances en tecnología el número de
víctimas fue mucho menor sin embargo la
ayuda para los municipios afectados no
es suficiente para la reparación de los
daños ocasionados
por los sismos
es el día en que
x
una
casualidad
lamentable
se padecieron de dos sismos
este 2020 la tragedia tiene un matiz
especial la fecha llega cuando la
pandemia del cobi 19 ha dejado más
muertos en méxico que lo ocasionado por
ambos terremotos combinados el sismo de
1985 dejó un saldo de entre 10 mil y 40
mil decesos desaparecidos mientras que
hace tres años el terremoto dejó menos
de 400 la pandemia ya deja más de 72 mil
fallecimientos en méxico el cuarto país
con más muertes a nivel mundial
[Música]